OK. As adults, it's pretty rare to have a moment where you're talking with somebody in your own country, in your own hometown, in your own language, and you have no idea what is actually happening, where things become confusing and not in that "oh, what did he mean by that?" sort of way, but in an I Love Lucy, "how did I get myself into this situation?" kind of confusion.
好的。作为成年人，我们很少会遇到这样的时刻：你在自己的国家、自己的家乡、用自己的母语和别人交谈，却完全不知道究竟发生了什么；那种困惑不是“哦，他那句话是什么意思？”的那种，而是一种像《我爱露西》里那种“我是怎么把自己搞到这种境地的？”的困惑。
Like, for example, Amy was back home in Indiana on a break from college. And she was accompanying her brother's high school class on a trip to this health and science museum they have in South Bend called the Healthworks Kids' Museum. And just to give you a sense of who the characters are in this story, Amy's brother is autistic, and he is developmentally disabled.
比如，艾米大学放假回到印第安纳的老家。她陪她弟弟的高中班级去南湾参观一个叫“健康工场儿童博物馆”的健康科学博物馆。为了让你了解这个故事里的人物，艾米的弟弟患有自闭症，且有发育障碍。
If you had to picture Ben, I would say picture this really handsome, star athlete-looking guy, who sort of has an age of maybe 5 to 8 years old and loves dinosaurs.
如果要你想象本（Ben）的样子，我会说想象一个长得非常帅、看起来像明星运动员的小伙子，他的心智大概只有5到8岁，而且特别喜欢恐龙。
As for Amy, aside from the fact that she's very close to her brother, you can get a good sense of who she is by the conversation that she had with Ben's teacher on the bus with all the developmentally disabled kids driving to this museum. Amy was talking to the teacher about her schoolwork, which, frankly, seems very, very hard. Amy was majoring in physics and studying in Germany.
至于艾米，除了她和弟弟关系非常亲密之外，你可以通过她在公共汽车上与本的老师交谈来了解她，当时车上载着所有去参观博物馆的发育障碍儿童。艾米在和老师谈论她的学业，老实说，这看起来非常非常难。艾米主修物理，还在德国留学。
In Germany, not only were the classes in German, but we were also using all of these graduate textbooks, and so. But she was really nice, and she just listened to me the whole way over.
在德国，不仅课程是用德语上的，我们还用了所有这些研究生级别的教科书，所以……但她人真的很好，她全程都在听我说话。
So they get to the museum. And after some videos and some science experiments where they blow things up, it was time to walk around the exhibits.
于是他们到了博物馆。在看完一些视频和做了一些爆炸科学实验后，是时候去参观各个展区了。
So during all of this, one of the things that they had been really pushing, they had these new computers that were installed. They were computers designed to walk kids through making a really neat identification card. And they were all really excited about this. I think they must have just gone live, like, the day before we came because they were all just-- make sure you use our ID computers. We're so excited about this. And you get to print out your ID, and pick it up at the front desk. And--
在这个过程中，他们一直在极力推广的一件事是，他们安装了新的电脑。这些电脑旨在引导孩子们制作一张非常酷的身份证。他们对此都非常兴奋。我想这些电脑一定是前一天才刚投入使用的，因为他们一直在说——一定要用我们的身份证电脑。我们对此太兴奋了。你可以打印出你的身份证，然后在前台领取。而且——
Right.
对。
And so when we walk out onto the actual museum part, my brother and I walk around, and he shows me some of his favorite exhibits. And this staff member comes up to me, and he says, have you made your ID yet?
所以当我们走进博物馆的实际参观区域时，我和我弟弟四处转了转，他给我展示了一些他最喜欢的展品。有个工作人员走过来对我说，你做身份证了吗？
Now, for a second, it seems a little weird that he would ask one of the adults to make an ID card. But Amy figured it's new. They're excited for everybody to try this thing, kids and adults. So her brother ambles off, and she sits down and starts answering the questions on her computer screen. And the guy doesn't go away. He keeps finding ways to help her.
现在，有一秒钟，我觉得他问一个成年人去制作身份证有点奇怪。但艾米觉得这是新东西，他们很兴奋，想让每个人，包括孩子和大人都试试。于是她弟弟慢悠悠地走开了，她坐下来开始回答电脑屏幕上的问题。那个男人并没有走开，他一直在找各种方法来帮助她。
Then it occurred to me, oh, well, maybe he's hitting on me a little bit.
然后我突然想到，哦，好吧，也许他是在跟我搭讪。
Which would make sense, but the help that he's giving her keeps getting stranger and stranger. He's giving her instructions for things that no fully functioning adult would ever need instructions for. And Amy wonders, does he think that she is one of the developmentally disabled kids who are wandering all over the museum? But at the same time, Amy thought it was completely obvious that she wasn't-- the way she moved, the way she expressed herself. And the guy's manner, his tone of voice was unmistakable. He talked to her like a peer.
这说得通，但他给她的帮助却越来越奇怪。他给她的指示是任何心智健全的成年人根本不需要指点的东西。艾米不禁怀疑，他是不是以为她也是在博物馆里到处晃悠的发育障碍儿童之一？但同时，艾米认为她看起来完全不像——她的动作方式、她的表达方式。而且那个男人的举止、语气都非常明显。他把她当成同龄人来对待。
I mean, I almost wonder if maybe that was why I was almost paralyzed with confusion. It's really rare to meet people who don't use some kind of special voice with the mentally disabled, this slightly higher pitched, slightly "I know you're a special person" kind of voice. So it was just-- it was so strange.
我是说，我甚至怀疑这可能就是我当时被困惑到几乎瘫痪的原因。很少遇到人们在面对智障人士时不使用那种特殊的语调，那种稍微提高一点音调、那种“我知道你是特殊人士”的语调。所以这真的很奇怪。
And then luckily, the very next question that comes up on the computer screen is one that Amy realizes can resolve all of this confusion once and for all, definitively, for the both of them.
幸运的是，电脑屏幕上出现的下一个问题让艾米意识到，这个问题可以一劳永逸地为他们双方彻底解决这种困惑。
So the question is, type in your age. OK, so I'm 21 years old at the time. So I'm thinking, I can type in 21, and he'll realize that I can't be a student. And we can just both pretend like we understood what was going on this whole time. So I type in 21. And he looks at me, and he looks at the age. And he says, oh, Amy, you know, if your age is a number that ends in "teen," then that number starts with a 1.
问题是，输入你的年龄。好吧，当时我21岁。所以我心想，我可以输入21，他就会意识到我不可能还是个学生。我们可以假装我们一直都明白是怎么回事。于是我输入了21。他看着我，又看了看年龄。然后他说，哦，艾米，你知道，如果你的年龄是一个以“teen”结尾的数字，那么这个数字是以1开头的。
So he just assumes you've typed wrong.
所以他直接假定你输错了。
Yeah. But I haven't. So at that point, I decide that instead of saying, OK, oh, actually, I am 21, and then letting that fold out however it would have, I erased what I typed, and I type in 18.
是的。但我没输错。所以在那一刻，我决定与其说，哦，其实我21岁了，然后让事情往不知名的方向发展，不如擦掉我输的，改成了18。
Why?
为什么？
Ah-- I don't know. I mean, I thought, how many more questions could there possibly be? I've already told them everything about myself, how much I weigh. And then I thought, well, this is just going to be a couple more questions. And then it'll take a photo of me, and then I'll be done. And then he'll never have to know.
啊……我不知道。我是想，还能有多少个问题呢？我已经把我的一切都告诉他了，连体重都说了。然后我想，好吧，这大概只需要再回答几个问题。接着拍张照，我就完事了。那样他就永远不必知道了。
He's a stranger. You're in a museum. This will be over in a minute. You can walk away. Who cares?
他是个陌生人。你在博物馆。这一切一分钟就结束了。你可以走开。谁在乎呢？
Exactly. I felt like it was the lesser of two evils at that point.
确实。我觉得在那一刻，这是两害相权取其轻。
But she is not near the end of the questionnaire-- far from it. It continues for pages and pages. Then there's a set of paragraph-length questions, which require actual concentration.
但她离问卷结束还远着呢——差得远。接下来还有好几页。然后是一组需要真正集中注意力的长段落问题。
And while I'm-- fast as I can, I'm skimming these questions, trying to get through these, he starts reading them to me out loud, word for word. And I'm sort of melting into my chair, and I'm thinking, this is too much. This is way too much of a deception. I have to somehow stop him. So I did. I said, oh, I can read. And then he looks at me. He puts his hand on my back, and he says, your parents must be so proud of you.
当我正尽可能快地扫视这些问题，试图做完它们时，他开始大声地逐字念给我听。我简直快要在椅子上融化了，心想，这太过分了。这种欺骗也太过了。我必须设法阻止他。所以我这么做了。我说，哦，我会认字。然后他看着我。他把手放在我的背上说，你的父母一定为你感到非常骄傲。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
So as you might imagine, I'm working really hard to skim through these questions as quick-- I'm a blur of activity. I'm just trying to get through these questions so I can get out of this room and escape. And as I'm working through these questions as fast as I can, I see my brother's teacher walking towards me. And she says, hey, Amy, how's it going?
你可以想象，我当时拼命想尽快扫完这些问题——我动作飞快。我只是想快点做完这些题，好离开这个房间逃走。当我正尽可能快地处理这些问题时，我看到我弟弟的老师朝我走来。她说，嘿，艾米，进展怎么样？
And you're thinking like, oh my God, what's going to happen?
你当时一定在想，天哪，会发生什么？
Oh. Oh. Yeah. And then it happens. He points to me, and he says-- again, voice full of admiration and pride. And he says, Amy was just telling me that she can read.
哦。哦。是的。然后事情发生了。他指着我说——语气再次充满了钦佩和自豪。他说，艾米刚才告诉我，她会认字。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And how does the teacher take this news?
老师听到这个消息后反应如何？
Oh my gosh! So this teacher, who I'd been complaining to about these graduate-level classes in German and--
天哪！所以这个老师，我之前一直跟她抱怨这些研究生水平的德语课，而且——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
[SIGHS] She looks at him, and she says, of course Amy can read.
[叹气] 她看着他，说道，艾米当然会认字。
And then the truth pours out. There begins a flurrying of apologizing on all sides, Amy apologizing to the guy, the guy apologizing to Amy, both of them, she says, clutching their own hearts as they do this. Turns out, he's so careful not to talk down to developmentally disabled students because he himself had a learning disability. And so she had misread what he was doing and why he spoke the way he did, and he misread who she really was. And in this case, they both discovered the truth.
随后真相大白。双方开始了一阵慌乱的道歉，艾米向那个人道歉，那个人向艾米道歉，她说他们两人在道歉时都紧紧按着自己的胸口。原来，他之所以那么小心不去用那种居高临下的态度对待发育障碍学生，是因为他自己就有学习障碍。所以她误解了他的所作所为和说话方式的原因，而他也误解了她的真实身份。在这个案例中，他们最终都发现了真相。
But just as often, people meet and walk away and never straighten this stuff out. They assume. They get it all wrong. And that is the subject of today's program. From Chicago Public Radio, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, I've Got You Pegged-- stories of people assuming all kinds of things about other people, usually in error. Our show today in four acts, and it is quite a lineup-- Richard Price, David Rakoff, Shalom Auslander, and Nancy Updike. Stay with us.
但同样常见的是，人们见面后各奔东西，从未澄清这些误会。他们假定。他们全搞错了。而这就是今天节目的主题。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“看透你了”——讲述人们对他人做出各种假设，通常都是错误的。我们今天的节目分为四幕，阵容相当强大——理查德·普莱斯、大卫·拉科夫、沙洛姆·奥斯兰德和南希·厄普代克。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Today's show is a rerun. Act 1, The Fat Blue Line. We begin today with a story about something that happens all the time in all kinds of places, something that is so common that it's not even big enough to make it on the local news. Richard Price tells the story, the novelist and screenwriter. He often writes about cops and crime. He wrote Clockers. He wrote Sea of Love. He wrote for the TV show The Wire. He told this story on stage at The Moth in New York back in 2008. He describes it as a tale taken from real life and dramatized.
这是《美国生活》。今天的节目是重播。第一幕，肥胖的蓝色防线。我们今天从一个在各种地方时常发生的故事开始，这件事太常见了，以至于连地方新闻都上不了。理查德·普莱斯讲述了这个故事，他是位小说家和编剧。他经常写警察和犯罪题材。他写过《Clockers》。他写过《海之恋》。他为电视剧《火线》写过剧本。他于2008年在纽约的“Moth”舞台上讲述了这个故事。他将其描述为一个取材于真实生活并戏剧化的故事。
In the last novel I wrote, I spent a lot of time on the Lower East Side. And as is my wont, I wound up in the back of police cars a lot. And the Lower East Side is a very low-crime area right now. It used to be the worst. But Giuliani and real estate pressure took care of that. And now they basically have nothing to do down there in terms of crime.
在我写的上一部小说里，我在下东区待了很长时间。按照我的习惯，我最后经常坐在警车后座。下东区现在是一个犯罪率很低的地区。过去那是这里最糟糕的地方。但朱利安尼和房地产压力解决了这个问题。现在他们在犯罪方面基本没什么事可做了。
So what they do is they sort of sit in fake taxis. Four beefy white guys sit in a fake taxi by the side of Williamsburg Bridge, and they eyeball what's coming over from Brooklyn. And if the car looks like a $200 shitbox or somebody's got an Afro or a ponytail, they pull up, pull in behind the car, and they wait to see if the guy's going to go all polite in his driving, like put on lane change signals. Then they know he's dirty.
所以他们做的事就是坐在假出租车里。四个壮实的白人坐在威廉斯堡大桥旁的一辆假出租车里，盯着从布鲁克林过来的车。如果那辆车看起来像一辆价值200美元的烂车，或者车主留着爆炸头或马尾辫，他们就会开车跟上去，跟在车后面，等着看那个人开车是否表现得特别有礼貌，比如打转向灯。那时候他们就知道那个人有问题。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And so worst comes to worse, it's fishing, really. It's a big fishing hole, Delancey Street. And so I spent all night in this bogus taxi with about 850 pounds of white beef.
所以最坏的情况，其实就是钓鱼。德兰西街是一个巨大的鱼塘。所以我在那辆假的士里和大约850磅的白人肌肉男待了一整晚。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And it's the end of the night. They made their collars. And there are two cops up front, and I'm sitting in the back. When I ride with these guys, I don't really comment about what they do. I don't engage them in any kind of debates. It's like, I'm there to bear witness and then see what I can do with it in my work. Anyways, they're riding up Essex Street. It's kind of Miller time.
那天快结束了。他们完成了抓捕。前面坐着两个警察，我坐在后面。当我和这些人在一起时，我通常不对他们的所作所为发表评论。我不参与任何辩论。就像是，我在那儿见证，然后看看我能在作品中如何运用它。不管怎样，他们开车沿着埃塞克斯街行驶。差不多到了下班时间。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And as they're going up, they pass a Black guy about 30 years old with dreads on a bicycle. And on the crossbars, he's got a white kid about 9, 10 years old. And the Black guy and the white kid, they're kind of chatting. The kid's looking up at the guy. They look like they're sort of familiar with each other.
当他们往上走时，他们经过一个30岁左右、留着脏辫的黑人，他正骑着自行车。在横梁上坐着一个9、10岁左右的白人小孩。那个黑人和白人小孩正在聊天。孩子抬头看着那个人。他们看起来好像很熟悉对方。
And the cops drive by, and they're dead silent. After about a block, one guy says to the other, says, hey, big guy, does that look fishy to you? He says, it's fucking midnight. What's going on here? They said, well, what do you want to do, big guy? So I'll tell you, big guy. All right, make the light. Pull over. Let's see what's what.
警察开车经过时，沉默得可怕。过了一个街区，一个人对另一个人说，嘿，大块头，那看起来可疑吗？他说，这都半夜了。这到底是怎么回事？他们说，那你想怎么办，大块头？我告诉你吧，大块头。好了，抓个现行。靠边停车。看看是怎么回事。
So they pull over. Bike's coming up Essex. One of the cops steps in the road, puts his hand down, and says, hey, how you doing? Get off the bike, please. And the Black guy gets off the bike, and he goes, hey, officers, like it's an unexpected treat-- you know, hi, what's up?
于是他们靠边停车。自行车沿着埃塞克斯街上来。其中一个警察走到路中间，把手压下，说，嘿，你好吗？请下车。那个黑人从自行车上下来，说，嘿，警官，就像是一个意外的惊喜——你知道，嗨，怎么了？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he says, did you ever hear of helmets? Oh, yeah. Gee, I'm really sorry. At which point, the other cop says to the little white kid, he says, hey, big guy, what's your name? He goes, um, Noah Rosenberg? Like he's not sure. He says, hey, Noah, come here, buddy. Come on over here. And he separates the two. And I'm sort of hopping in between the two conversations at this point.
他说，你听说过头盔吗？哦，是啊。天哪，真的很抱歉。就在这时，另一个警察对那个白人小男孩说，嘿，大块头，你叫什么名字？他说，嗯，诺亚·罗森伯格？好像他不确定。他说，嘿，诺亚，过来，哥们。过来这边。他把两人分开了。而我此时在两段对话之间来回穿梭。
And the Black guy tries to follow the white kid, and the other cop puts his hand on his chest and he says, no, you stay over here. Let me see some ID. He says, what? He says, some ID. He says, don't look at him. Look at me. He says, no, no, I was just picking him up from a play date. Did I ask you that? No, no. You don't understand. I work the bar at Schiller's.
黑人试图跟着白人小孩，另一个警察把手放在他的胸口说，不，你留在这儿。给我看点证件。他说，什么？他说，证件。他说，别看他。看我。他说，不，不，我只是刚接他参加完游戏聚会。我问你那个了吗？没有，没有。你不明白。我在席勒酒吧工作。
And again, did I ask you that? Well, no. He said, why are you trying to divert me? He said, go down the same road as me. He goes, OK, OK. And he gives him the ID, and at which point, he sort of waves to the kid. And he goes, oh, what did I just say to you? He says, no, no, I'm really sorry. It's Noah. He's kind of wound a little tight. He says, oh, really? He says, have a seat, and he points to the curb. He makes the guy sit on the curb with his feet in the gutter.
又来了，我问你那个了吗？好吧，没有。他说，你为什么要转移我的注意力？他说，跟我走同一条路。他说，好，好。他给了他证件，就在这时，他向那个孩子招了招手。他说，哦，我刚才跟你说什么来着？他说，不，不，我真的很抱歉。这是诺亚。他有点紧张。他说，哦，真的吗？他说，坐下，并指着路缘石。他让那个人坐在路缘石上，脚放在排水沟里。
And he says, so where are you going? He says, well, I had the late shift. And he says, it's kind of late to be driving around with a kid on a bike, isn't it? At which point, I leave those two, and I go over to Noah and the other cop. And he says, so your name's Noah, huh? And the kid says, yes. And for the millionth time, I don't have an ark.
他说，你们去哪儿？他说，哦，我上了晚班。他说，大半夜骑自行车带着个孩子，不太合适吧？就在这时，我离开了那两个，走向诺亚和另一个警察。他说，所以你叫诺亚，是吧？孩子说，是的。而且第一百万次了，我没有方舟。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the cop says, boy, you must get that a lot. The kid goes, oh, my God, you have no idea. And he says, so Noah, how old are you? He says, well, next week, I'll be a decade old. Well, that's great. Great. And where do you live? He says, 333 Avenue B. He says, and you go to school around here? He says, yes, I go to the Earth School. And he says, oh, cool. And who do you live with? He says, I live with my mom. And he goes, who's that over there?
警察说，孩子，你肯定常听这个吧。孩子说，天哪，你根本不知道。他说，那么诺亚，你几岁了？他说，嗯，下周我就十岁了。哦，太棒了。太好了。你住哪儿？他说，B大道333号。他说，你在这附近上学吗？他说，是的，我上地球学校。他说，哦，酷。你和谁住在一起？他说，我和妈妈住。他说，那边那个人是谁？
He says, well, I don't know who your friend is, but my friend is Cleve. And he says, oh, do you know what Cleve's last name is? He says, yeah, Carter. Cleve Carter. Sometimes I call him Coca-Cola. Sometimes I call him Carbon Copy.
他说，好吧，我不知道你的朋友是谁，但我的朋友是克里夫。他说，哦，你知道克里夫的姓吗？他说，知道，卡特。克里夫·卡特。有时我叫他可口可乐。有时我叫他复印件。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He says, oh, do you know him for long? I said, well, yeah, like 1, 1 and 1/4 years. He's kind of like my godfather since my other godfather died. Oh. And what do you guys do? Well, he was taking me home from a play date to my mom's. Says, so he knows your mom? And he says, well, yeah, he and my mom are kind of like friends. He says, well, kind of like? Well, they have sleepover dates.
他说，你们认识很久了吗？我说，嗯，是的，大概一年零三个月吧。他就像我的教父，因为我另一个教父去世了。哦。你们在一起做什么？嗯，他正带我从游戏聚会回我妈妈那里。说，所以他认识你妈妈？他说，嗯，是啊，他和我的妈妈就像是朋友。他说，嗯，像什么朋友？嗯，他们有留宿约会。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he says, so your mom knows that you're with him now? He says, well, my mom sent him to pick me up. My dad lives in Woodstock. He said, OK, at which point, I'm going, OK, let's see what's happening with Cleve. I walk over there. Cleve's sitting on-- he's sitting on the curb, and he's got his feet out there. And he's trying to make it look like it's natural. So he's massaging his deep thigh muscles like he's limbering up for the marathon or something. It's just humiliating as shit.
他说，所以你妈妈知道你现在跟他在一起吗？他说，嗯，我妈妈派他来接我的。我爸爸住在伍德斯托克。他说，好吧，就在这时，我在想，好吧，看看克里夫那边发生了什么。我走过去。克里夫坐在路缘石上，双脚伸在那里。他正试图让这一切看起来很自然。所以他正在按摩他的大腿肌肉，就像是在为马拉松热身一样。这真是丢人到家了。
And he's kind of smiling because you can't win. You got to play through. And he's sitting there. And the other cop is hitting his driver's license with a mag light, one of those big powerful flashlights. And he goes, so Cleveland, I see you're from Ohio. And he says--
他还在微笑，因为你赢不了。你只能硬着头皮演下去。他坐在那儿。另一个警察正用强光手电筒照着他的驾照，就是那种功率很大的手电筒。他说，所以克利夫兰，我看到你是俄亥俄州的。他说——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He says, yeah. He says, Cleveland from Ohio. He says, well, actually, it's from Oxford. And the guy goes, oh, Miami College. And he goes, yeah, yeah, that's where I went. And the cop goes, oh, Wally Szczerbiak, who's this big basketball player. And he goes, well, yeah, Wally was a little before my time. He said, oh, did you play ball for them, too? He said, well, not basketball, I played soccer. Oh, that's amazing because I teach soccer. I coach soccer out on the island, the kids' league. And he says, that's amazing. I keep waiting for that sport to blow up. But I don't think it's-- you know.
他说，是的。他说，来自俄亥俄州的克利夫兰。他说，好吧，其实是来自牛津。那个人说，哦，迈阿密大学。他说，对，对，那是我去的地方。警察说，哦，沃利·斯泽比亚克，那个很有名的大篮球运动员。他说，嗯，对，沃利比我那一届稍微早一点。他说，哦，你也为他们打球吗？他说，嗯，不是篮球，我踢足球。哦，那太棒了，因为我教足球。我在岛上教足球，带儿童联赛。他说，那太棒了。我一直在等那个运动火起来。但我觉得它……你知道。
And Cleveland's going, yeah, yeah, that's amazing, sitting just like this, at which point a Mustang comes by with two Black guys in it and-- up Essex. And the guy in the shotgun seat looks out the window, and he sees Cleveland sitting on the curb. And he starts yelling out, homeboy to base, homeboy to base. We got a Black man down. I repeat, a Black man down.
克利夫兰说，是啊，是啊，那太棒了，就像这样坐着，就在这时，一辆野马跑车载着两个黑人沿着埃塞克斯街过来了。坐在副驾驶位置的人向窗外看，看到克利夫兰坐在路缘石上。他开始大喊，伙计呼叫基地，伙计呼叫基地。我们抓到一个黑人了。重复一遍，一个黑人。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And he's laughing his ass off. And the Mustang floors it. And Cleveland's kind of squinting, and he's kind of looking the other way. He's just like, mortified. And hopping back to the other cop with the kid, he says, so Noah, does Cleveland live with you? He goes, no, Cleveland lives at 444 Avenue D. We live at 332 Avenue B.
他笑得不行。野马车全速开走了。克利夫兰眯着眼，转过头去。他简直感到羞愧难当。回到带着那个孩子的警察那里，他说，所以诺亚，克利夫兰和你住一起吗？他回答，不，克利夫兰住在D大道444号。我们住在B大道332号。
He says, well, you ever been over to his house? He says, only about a million times. And he says, mostly with your mom, I guess, huh? He says, and by myself. He said, oh, really? What do you do there? And he says, well, sometimes we walk his dog. It's a Rhodesian Ridgeback named Mars. And one time, he tried to teach me how to make scrambled eggs. But I don't really like his oven because you light the pilot match, and it goes, fwoosh. And it scares me.
他说，那么你去过他家吗？他说，大概有一百万次了吧。他说，大部分时间是和你妈妈一起吧，嗯？他说，还有我自己去。他说，哦，真的吗？你在那儿做什么？他说，嗯，有时我们去遛他的狗。是一只叫马斯的罗德西亚背脊犬。有一次，他教我怎么做炒蛋。但我不怎么喜欢他的烤箱，因为你要点燃那个引火火柴，然后它会“呼”地一声。那吓到我了。
And he says, one time, my mom had to go to court in Woodstock, and I stayed with Cleveland for three days. And he said, in court, huh? He said, yeah. Three days? He said, yeah. He said, but mostly, I'd say 82 and 1/2% of the time we watch television. You and Cleveland? He said, yeah, me and Cleveland. He goes-- and the cop said to him, do you ever do anything else with him? And he goes, what? What do you mean? He goes, do you do anything else with him?
他说，有一次，我妈妈不得不去伍德斯托克出庭，我在克利夫兰那里住了三天。他说，出庭，嗯？他说，是的。三天？他说，是的。他说，但大部分时间，我会说82.5%的时间我们都在看电视。你和克利夫兰？他说，是的，我和克利夫兰。他说……警察对他说，你除了这些还和他做别的事吗？他问，什么？你什么意思？他问，你还和他做别的事吗？
And all of a sudden, the kid's eyes get really big and kind of wet, like steel. And the kid starts kind of-- kind of breathing kind of heavy. And the cop starts shaking a little bit. And the cop says to him, he says, hey, Noah, look at this. And he pulls his jacket back, and he shows him his detective shield on his belt. He says, do you know what that is? He says, yeah, it's a police badge. He says, you know what this means? He says, what? He says, that means you can tell me anything you want, and you'll be perfectly safe. Do you understand that?
突然，孩子的眼睛变得很大，有点湿润，像钢一样。孩子开始有点呼吸沉重。警察开始有点发抖。警察对他说，嘿，诺亚，看这个。他拉开他的夹克，露出腰带上的侦探徽章。他说，你知道那是什么吗？他说，知道，那是警徽。他说，你知道这意味着什么吗？他说，什么？他说，这意味着你可以告诉我任何你想说的事，你会非常安全。你明白吗？
And the kid looks at him, and he goes, oh, my god, are you going to arrest him? And the cop-- his heart's pumping Kool-Aid, and he starts moving over. And he says, why? And the kid goes, if you fucking assholes arrest him again one more time just because he's Black, and I'm not, I'm going to kill myself.
孩子看着他说，天哪，你要逮捕他吗？警察——他的心跳加速，开始靠近。他说，为什么？孩子说，如果你们这些混蛋因为他是黑人、我不是，而再次逮捕他，我就自杀。
You came into my apartment and dragged him out because the crazy lady next door said he was a rapist. You put him in handcuffs when he came to pick me up at school. You pulled him away from me at the street fair and made me wait for my mom. I swear to God, I'm going to lose my mind.
你们闯进我家公寓把他强行带走，仅仅因为隔壁那个疯女人说他是强奸犯。当他来学校接我时，你们给他戴上了手铐。你们在街头集市把他从我身边拉走，让我等我妈妈。我发誓，我快要疯了。
And the cops go, whoa, easy, easy, easy. At which point, both cops are looking at each other like, well, what's going on? And all of a sudden, Cleveland sees the kid's losing it, and he goes, hey, Noah, buddy. And the cop goes, what did I just say to you? Stop talking to the kid. And at which point, Cleveland says, Officer, do you want to put this to rest? I tell you what. I'm reaching for my cell phone in here. He says, why don't you call-- why don't you call the kid's mom and just see what's going on?
警察说，哇，冷静，冷静，冷静。就在这时，两个警察互相看着，心想，这到底是怎么回事？突然，克利夫兰看到孩子要崩溃了，说，嘿，诺亚，哥们。警察说，我刚才跟你说什么来着？别跟孩子说话。就在这时，克利夫兰说，警官，你想结束这一切吗？我告诉你。我正伸手拿我的手机。他说，你为什么不打个电话——你为什么不给孩子的妈妈打个电话，看看是怎么回事？
He says, I'll call the kid's mom. He says, what's her name? She goes, Idina. And he calls across to the other cop, get the kid's mother's name. And the kid, through sobs, is going, Idina. And Cleveland gives the cop the mother's number. The cop calls, and he says, hey, how you doing? This is Sergeant Daley from the 7th Precinct. Who am I speaking to? And she goes, oh, my god, Idina Rosenberg. What happened?
他说，我来打。他说，她叫什么名字？她叫伊迪娜。他对着另一个警察喊，问出孩子母亲的名字。孩子抽泣着说，伊迪娜。克利夫兰把母亲的号码给了警察。警察打了过去，说，嘿，你好吗？我是第七分局的戴利警长。请问是谁？她说，天哪，我是伊迪娜·罗森伯格。发生什么事了？
He goes, nothing happened. I just need to know, do you know where your son is right now? At which point, she freaks. She goes, where is he? What happened? He's supposed to be with Cleveland. He's supposed to be taking him home from a play date. What happened? What happened? What happened? Well, no, no, no. He's fine. OK. At which point, the kid goes, my mom says, if I get any more nervous, I'm going to have to live with my father in Woodstock, you fuck!
他说，没发生什么。我只是需要知道，你知道你儿子现在在哪里吗？就在这时，她抓狂了。她说，他在哪儿？发生什么事了？他应该和克利夫兰在一起。他应该带他从游戏聚会回家的。怎么了？发生什么事了？发生什么事了？嗯，不，不，不。他很好。好的。就在这时，孩子说，我妈妈说，如果我再紧张一点，我就得搬去伍德斯托克和我爸爸住了，你这个混蛋！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the cops are going, no, no, no, the kid's great. The kid's fine. The only thing is, they were riding without helmets. And it's a serious safety violation. And she's just going, oh, my god. Oh, Jesus. She says, no, no, no. OK, don't worry about it. All right. All right. All right. Good night. Have a good night, and hangs up. At which point, they bring Cleveland and Noah together again, and they give them this half-assed lecture on bicycle safety.
警察们说，不，不，不，孩子很好。孩子没事。唯一的问题是，他们没戴头盔骑车。这是严重的交通安全违规。而她只是说，天哪。哦，上帝。她说，不，不，不。好的，别担心。好了。好了。好了。晚安。祝晚安，然后挂断了电话。就在这时，他们把克利夫兰和诺亚聚在一起，给他们上了一堂敷衍了事的自行车安全课。
And he says, I'm supposed to write you up, but I'm going to give you a pass this time. And Cleveland's still kind of smiling, but the smile doesn't go past here. It never reaches his eyes. And he gets back on the bike, and the kid gets on the handlebars. And the kid's going through that post-crying jag, shudder withdrawal. And Cleveland's kind of talking him down as he sort of pushes off, and they go disappear up Essex.
他说，我本应该给你们开罚单，但这次放你们一马。克利夫兰仍然微笑着，但微笑没到眼底。它从未传达到他的眼睛里。他骑上自行车，孩子坐上车把。孩子还在经历那种哭泣后的阵颤。克利夫兰一边推车离开，一边安抚他，他们消失在埃塞克斯街上。
And we get back in the police car. And I'm sitting in the back. I'm not saying a fucking thing. And they go in dead silence for about two blocks. And one cop finally says to the other, he says, you know something, big guy? And the other guy says, what's that, big guy? He says, still feels fishy to me.
我们回到警车上。我坐在后面。我一句混蛋话都没说。他们沉默地开了两个街区。其中一个警察终于对另一个说，嘿，你知道吗，大块头？另一个人说，什么事，大块头？他说，我还是觉得这事可疑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the other cop says, hey, we gave it a shot, man. That's all we can do. Thank you.
另一个警察说，嘿，我们试过了，伙计。我们只能做到这一步。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼声]
Richard Price. His latest novel is called Lazarus Man. The story was recorded by The Moth, which, of course, is a podcast with all kinds of stories like the one you just heard at themoth.org, or find it wherever you get your podcasts.
理查德·普莱斯。他的最新小说叫《拉撒路人》。这个故事由“Moth”录制，当然，这是一个拥有各种像你刚才听到的那种故事的播客，网址是themoth.org，或者在任何你获取播客的地方都能找到。
Act 2, Yes, No, or Baby. Well, there's a simple rule designed to help us all fight the urge to pigeonhole other people based on a first impression. And I speak, of course, of don't judge a book by its cover. But this axiom, this adage, this maxim, is deeply flawed, and not just because of its annoyingly scoldy self-righteousness.
第二幕，是，不是，还是宝贝。好吧，有一个简单的规则，旨在帮助我们所有人抵制根据第一印象去把他人归类的冲动。我指的当然是不要以貌取人。但这个公理、这句格言、这句箴言，是有严重缺陷的，不仅仅是因为它那种令人讨厌的唠叨般的自以为是。
The fact is, there are times in life where you must judge a person based on woefully little information crammed into some cover letter, or something like that, that they have put together. One of our show's producers, Nancy Updike, visited somebody in this very judgy situation.
事实是，人生中有时你必须根据求职信中挤出的极其有限的信息，或其他类似的东西来判断一个人。我们节目的制片人之一，南希·厄普代克，就在这种充满判断力的情况下探访了一个人。
Anyone who's not a megalomaniac feels daunted by the prospect of having to separate a group of strangers into a yes pile and a no pile. Kim Schwary is seven months pregnant, and she's facing on her coffee table in Seattle dozens of one-page letters from couples who want to adopt her baby.
任何不是自大狂的人，在想到要把一群陌生人分成“是”和“否”两堆时，都会感到畏缩。金·施瓦里怀孕七个月了，她正面对着西雅图自家咖啡桌上数十封想领养她孩子的夫妇写的求职信。
Individually, each letter seems like not enough information, and collectively, they are way, way too much. The first time she read through them, they melted into an indistinguishable mass of thoughtful, intelligent, fun-loving, mutually supportive, healthy, active, outdoorsy couples.
单独看，每一封信似乎信息都不够，而合在一起看，信息又实在太多了。她第一次读的时候，它们融合成了难以区分的一堆，全都是体贴、聪明、热爱生活、互相支持、健康、积极、热爱户外的夫妇。
A lot of the hobbies are similar, just hiking, couples from the Northwest, too, I'm sure that's common. So like even just this page-- hiking, snowshoeing, camping.
很多爱好都一样，就是徒步旅行，西北地区的夫妇也一样，我相信这很常见。所以连这一页也是——徒步旅行、雪鞋健行、露营。
And if you turn to the next page, is there also a hiking part?
如果你翻到下一页，有没有徒步旅行的部分？
Let's see. Probably. Oh, yes, hiking. There you go. [LAUGHS]
看看。可能有。哦，有，徒步旅行。你看。[笑声]
Kim's doing an open adoption, which means that she will have a relationship with the family who adopts her child for the rest of her life. The cover letters are just the beginning of a long, long process. The whole thing is sort of like super high stakes online dating. Judging people is required. Kim goes back and forth between practical considerations and pure gut checks.
金正在进行开放式领养，这意味着她余生都将与领养她孩子的家庭保持联系。求职信只是漫长过程的开始。这一切就像是超高风险的在线约会。必须去评判别人。金在实际考虑和纯粹的直觉判断之间摇摆不定。
Here's something. This couple has another child, and they're talking-- I don't know. They use kind of like child talk when they're talking about him. Like, it says something about "kissing his boo-boos" or something. And that kind of-- I don't know. I don't like that very much.
看看这个。这对夫妇有另一个孩子，他们在谈论……我不知道。他们在谈论他时用了某种孩子气的语言。比如，上面写着关于“亲吻他的小伤口”之类的。那种……我不知道。我不太喜欢那个。
Kim ends up liking a different couple that already has a little boy. She likes the idea that her baby would have a sibling. She weeds out a family that seems to her too religious. And later, she frowns on a couple who both have high-powered jobs that they write about at length. She wonders if they'd be home enough for the baby.
金最后喜欢上了另一对已经有个小男孩的夫妇。她喜欢她的孩子能有个兄弟姐妹的想法。她排除掉了一个她觉得太宗教的家庭。后来，她对一对都拥有高压职业的夫妇表示反感，信中花了大量篇幅写工作。她怀疑他们是否能有足够的时间陪孩子。
These guys, I could see them working 50, 60 hours a week because of their careers.
这些人，我能看出他们因为职业原因会每周工作50、60个小时。
A few pages later, Kim makes a face when a couple says they're "relational people."
几页之后，当一对夫妇说他们是“重关系的人”时，金露出了厌恶的表情。
I'm wondering exactly what that meant. There's this whole packet of information, and then I'll focus on this sentence that maybe I don't like. And that makes me feel like I'm really kind of judgmental when I do this. And sometimes that doesn't always feel good. See, and this is something really small, but for some reason, it's-- it says, "the opportunity to have a relationship with the child's biological heritage is very important, including medical history." I just-- that feels kind of weird to me.
我在想那到底是什么意思。有一整包信息，然后我就会盯着这句话，可能我不喜欢它。这让我觉得自己这样做时真的很势利。有时这感觉并不好。看，这只是件小事，但出于某种原因……它上面写着，“拥有与孩子生物血缘关系建立联系的机会非常重要，包括医疗记录。”我只是……这对我来说感觉有点奇怪。
It's a little clinical.
有点临床冷漠。
Right, it is a little clinical. I want to be more than medical records, so.
对，是有点临床冷漠。我想成为不仅仅是医疗记录，所以。
So that kind of put you off right there?
所以那种说法让你感到反感了吗？
Yeah. So it goes back to that judgmental thing, you know? Because I mean, I've written things, and maybe that's not how they meant to portray themselves, but it does, like you said, sound very clinical, and-- yeah.
是的。所以这又回到了那种评判心理，你知道吗？因为我的意思是，我也写过东西，也许他们并不是那样想表达自己，但就像你说的，听起来非常临床冷漠，而且……是的。
Just like Kim's having to quickly peg these families, extrapolating all sorts of important things from just words on a page and a few pictures, she's finding that as a single woman, pregnant, people are making all kinds of assumptions about her. Co-workers assume she's married and starting a family. Those are awkward conversations. And if she tells someone what's really going on, that she's putting the baby up for adoption, she better be prepared for a lecture.
就像金不得不快速给这些家庭贴标签，仅从书面文字和几张照片中推断出各种重要事项一样，她发现作为一个未婚怀孕的单身女性，人们也在对她做出各种假设。同事们假设她已婚并开始组建家庭。那些对话很尴尬。如果她告诉别人到底发生了什么，她要把孩子送去领养，她最好做好被说教的准备。
I mean, you're really kind of vulnerable when you're pregnant. And you're kind of-- you're vulnerable to judgment, I guess. People are very prone to-- once you say what you're doing, they tell you what they would do and not do. And they want to be like, oh, I think you're going to be really upset. And I think this. And I'm like, no, I think maybe you're the one who's upset, not me. But--
我是说，当你怀孕时，你真的很脆弱。而且你有点……我想你很容易受到评判。人们非常倾向于——一旦你说出你在做什么，他们就会告诉你他们会怎么做或不怎么做。他们想说，哦，我觉得你会很难过。我觉得这个那个。我心想，不，我觉得也许难过的是你，不是我。但是……
She says some people are utterly convinced that adoption is just a bad idea all around, which Kim takes personally since she was adopted. It's one of the reasons she didn't want to get an abortion.
她说有些人完全确信领养在各方面都是个坏主意，金对此感到很受伤，因为她自己就是被领养的。这也是她不想堕胎的原因之一。
People feel that if you're adopted that you have this great sense of loss, or you just don't know who you are, and there's some identity-- there's an identity crisis, and you feel abandoned. And that's not how I felt with my experience.
人们觉得如果你是被领养的，你会有种巨大的失落感，或者你不知道自己是谁，还有某种身份……存在身份危机，你感到被遗弃。但在我的经历中，我并没有那种感觉。
Being adopted?
被领养？
Being adopted, exactly. I felt very loved by my parents. The baby's father told me that he thought that-- I don't know why he said this, but he said that-- or he kind of assumed and said this, that he was so much closer to his parents than I was to mine, which isn't true at all. [LAUGHS] And it's just-- that's how he felt things must be.
被领养，没错。我感到父母非常爱我。孩子的父亲告诉我，他认为——我不知道他为什么要这么说，但他说了——或者他假设并说了，他与父母的关系比我与父母的关系亲近得多，这完全不是事实。[笑声] 这只是……那是他觉得事情必然的样子。
I waited till just about the end of my interview with Kim to confess that I'd had her pegged all wrong before I spoke to her. I thought she'd be a teenager, confused. But Kim is 27, has her own apartment, a good job.
我等到采访快结束时才坦白，在和金交谈之前，我完全把她看错了。我以为她是个困惑的青少年。但金27岁了，有自己的公寓，有份好工作。
Right. I'm in a situation where it would be very feasible that I would raise the child on my own. So it's probably harder to understand.
没错。我现在的情况是，独自抚养孩子是非常可行的。所以可能比较难理解。
OK, so people are making that judgment about you. What don't they know about you that would make them understand?
好的，所以人们在对你做出那种判断。有什么关于你的事情是他们不知道的，如果知道的话会让他们理解？
I don't know. I kind of have this unusual kind of circumstances that I was engaged, and my fiancé passed away. And after that, I kind of think I was lonely and looking for someone. I feel like I made a mistake, you know? I still miss my fiancé and think about him all the time. And I just-- I don't feel like I'm emotionally ready to raise a child. I feel like I could. But I just feel like it's not the right time. And--
我不知道。我有一种不寻常的情况，我曾经订过婚，但未婚夫去世了。在那之后，我想我是因为孤独而在寻找某人。我觉得我犯了个错，你知道吗？我依然想念我的未婚夫，一直想起他。我只是……我觉得我在情感上还没准备好抚养孩子。我觉得我能做到。但我就是觉得现在不是合适的时机。而且……
Especially if it's something that you guys talked about doing together, and here you are.
尤其是如果那是你们曾讨论过一起做的事，而现在却变成这样。
Right, exactly. I mean, we were always going to have kids together. And here I am, single and pregnant with some guy, who's just a kind of insignificant fellow. And it certainly isn't-- things aren't going in the way that they were supposed to or as planned. And-- right.
对，完全正确。我的意思是，我们原本打算一起要孩子的。而现在我却成了单身，怀着某个家伙的孩子，他只是一个无名小卒。这绝对不是……事情没有按照原本预想的那样发展。而且……对。
Kim doesn't go into her reasons with most people, so they make assumptions about her that she doesn't bother to correct. And she flips through dozens of letters from couples and makes assumptions about them that they'll never get a chance to respond to. It's the way of the world. Everyone's a judge, and everyone's the accused. And every day, things aren't going the way they were supposed to or as planned.
金不会和大多数人谈论她的原因，所以他们会对她做出她懒得纠正的假设。她翻阅着几十封来自夫妇的信件，并对他们做出他们永远没机会反驳的假设。这就是世道。每个人都是法官，每个人也都是被告。每一天，事情都没有按照预想的那样发展。
[ENGINE REVVING, PAGES FLIPPING]
[引擎加速声，翻页声]
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act 3, Isn't It Romantic? Well, our show today is about people jumping to conclusions about what others are like. And what we turn to now is corny, stereotyped ideas people have, and in this case, put into Broadway shows.
第三幕，难道不浪漫吗？好吧，我们今天的节目是关于人们对他人是什么样的人匆忙得出结论。我们现在要转向人们心中俗气、刻板的观念，在这种情况下，是关于百老汇演出。
This story is about a kind of iconic, old musical, the show Rent. And when that show came out in the 1990s, one of our contributors, David Rakoff, was not a fan. That show-- maybe you've seen it, or you've seen the movie-- was about New Yorkers in their 20s. David Rakoff had been a New Yorker in his 20s during the same era depicted in that show, and he thought the play made some mistakes.
这个故事是关于一部标志性的老音乐剧《吉屋出租》（Rent）。当那部剧在90年代上映时，我们的一位撰稿人，大卫·拉科夫，并不是它的粉丝。那部剧——也许你看过，或者看过电影——是关于20多岁的纽约人。大卫·拉科夫在电影描写的同一时代也是个20多岁的纽约人，他认为这部剧犯了一些错误。
There are 525,600 minutes in a year.
一年有525,600分钟。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I learned that from watching Rent.
我是从看《吉屋出租》里学到这个的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
From watching Rent, I also learned that the best way to mark the passing of these 525,600 minutes would be to measure them out into something Jonathan Larson, the writer of the musical, called "seasons of love." What does that even mean, "seasons of love"? In Rent, the characters live out their seasons of love in huge lofts. Some of them have AIDS, which is coincidentally also the name of a dreaded global pandemic that is still raging and has killed millions of people worldwide. In Rent, however, AIDS seems to be a disease that renders one cuter and cuter.
从看《吉屋出租》里，我还学到衡量这525,600分钟流逝的最佳方式，是将其划分为某种乔纳森·拉尔森（音乐剧作者）所谓的“爱之季节”。那到底是什么意思，“爱之季节”？在《吉屋出租》里，角色们生活在巨大的阁楼里，度过他们的爱之季节。其中一些人患有艾滋病，顺便说一句，这也是一种正在全球肆虐、夺走数百万生命的可怕全球流行病。然而在《吉屋出租》里，艾滋病似乎是一种让患者变得越来越可爱的疾病。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The characters are artists, creative types. They have tatterdemalion clothes. Some of them are homosexual, and the ones who aren't homosexual don't even seem to mind. They screen their calls, and when it is their parents, they roll their eyes. They hate their parents.
角色们都是艺术家、创意人士。他们穿着破烂的衣服。其中一些是同性恋，而那些不是同性恋的人似乎也完全不介意。他们筛选电话，当父母打来时，他们翻白眼。他们讨厌父母。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They are never going back to Larchmont, no way. They will stay here, living in their 2,000 square feet of picturesque poverty, being sexually free and creative. Here are some ways to broadcast creativity in a movie. Start plinking out a tune on a piano. Scratch a few notes on some music paper. Plink some more. Suddenly crash both hands down on the keyboard. Then bring them quickly up to your head, and grab the hair at your temple, screaming, it won't work!
他们永远不会回到拉奇蒙特，没门。他们会待在这里，住在他们2000平方英尺如画般的贫困中，保持性自由和创造力。以下是一些在电影中广播创造力的方式。在钢琴上开始叮叮当当地弹奏。在乐谱纸上潦草地写几个音符。再叮叮当当几下。突然把双手狠狠砸在琴键上。然后迅速将它们举到头边，抓住太阳穴的头发，尖叫道：它行不通！
Or sit at a typewriter, reading the page you've just written. Realize that it's shit, and tear it from the platen and toss it behind you. Cut to wastepaper basket overflowing with crumpled paper. Here's what they do in Rent to show that they are creative-- nothing! They do nothing!
或者坐在打字机前，读着刚才写的那一页。意识到那是垃圾，把它从滚筒上撕下来扔到身后。切换到装满揉皱纸团的纸篓。这就是他们在《吉屋出租》中所做的展现他们富有创造力的方式——什么都不做！他们什么都不做！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They hang out. And hanging out can be marvelous, but hanging out does not make you an artist. A secondhand wardrobe does not make you an artist. Neither do a hair-trigger temper, melancholic nature, propensity for tears, hating your parents, nor even HIV. I hate to say it. None of these can make you an artist.
他们闲逛。闲逛可以是美妙的，但闲逛不会让你成为艺术家。二手衣橱不会让你成为艺术家。火爆的脾气、忧郁的性格、流泪的倾向、讨厌你的父母，甚至艾滋病毒都不会。我很遗憾这么说。这些都不能让你成为艺术家。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They can help.
它们可以帮上忙。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But just as being gay does not make one witty, you can suck a mile of cock, it does not make you Oscar Wilde. Believe me, I know. I've tried.
但正如身为同性恋并不会让人变得机智一样，你可以吸一英里长的鸡巴，但这不会让你成为奥斯卡·王尔德。相信我，我知道。我试过。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The only thing that makes you an artist is making art. And that takes the opposite of hanging out. So when they sing the anthem of the show, that's a lie, really. Every song in the show is an anthem delivered with adolescent earnestness. It's like being trapped in the pages of a teenager's diary. So when they sing the title anthem of the show, "We're not going to pay this year's rent," followed by a kind of barked cheer of "rent, rent, rent, rent, rent, rent, rent," my only question is, well, why aren't you going to pay this year's rent?
唯一能让你成为艺术家的是创作艺术。而那需要与闲逛完全相反的东西。所以当他们唱起剧中的赞美诗时，那其实是个谎言。剧中的每一首歌都是以一种青春期的恳切交付的赞美诗。就像被困在青少年的日记页里一样。所以当他们唱起剧中的同名赞美诗“我们今年不交房租”时，紧接着是一种近乎咆哮的欢呼“房租、房租、房租、房租、房租、房租、房租”，我唯一的问题是，好吧，为什么你们今年不交房租？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It seems that they're not going to pay this year's rent because rent is for losers and uncreative types. Rent is for suits. By contrast, they are the last bastion of artistic purity. They have not sold out, and yet their brilliance goes unacknowledged. So fuck you, yuppie scum. I know what it's like to feel angry and ignored. I lived in Brooklyn a long time ago, about a block away from a prison.
看起来他们今年不交房租，因为房租是失败者和缺乏创造力的人交的。房租是西装革履的人交的。相比之下，他们是艺术纯洁性的最后堡垒。他们没有出卖自己，然而他们的才华却得不到承认。去你的，雅痞人渣。我知道那种感到愤怒和被忽视的感觉。很久以前我住在布鲁克林，离监狱大约一个街区。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
During the day, the neighborhood bustled with lawyers, judges, criminals, bail bondsmen, private detectives. I lived on a block in a little two-story building that had once been a coach house in the 19th century, and the basement had a red dirt floor. On the ground floor below me was an office that did what exactly? Resumes? I can't remember.
白天，那个社区挤满了律师、法官、罪犯、保释担保人和私人侦探。我住在一个小街区，是一栋在19世纪曾经是马车房的两层建筑，地下室是红土铺的地。在我楼下的底层是一个办公室，到底是做什么的？简历？我不记得了。
What I do remember is the man whose office it was. Raul was knee-bucklingly handsome. If my life had been different, like-- I don't know-- if I were like a hot girl with a driver's license, I could have put on a tube top and gone outside to wash my car in slow motion or something. But alas.
我记得的是那个拥有办公室的人。劳尔长得帅得让人膝盖发软。如果我的生活不同，比如——我不知道——如果我是个有驾照的辣妹，我可以穿上管状背心去外面慢动作洗车之类的。但可惜啊。
Once, during the day-- it must have been the weekend because I was at home-- I could hear Raul having sex in the office downstairs. I skittered around my apartment like a cockroach on a frying pan, trying not to make any noise while desperately looking for a knothole in the crappy floorboards.
有一次，在白天——那肯定是周末，因为我在家——我能听到劳尔在楼下的办公室做爱。我在我的公寓里像煎锅上的蟑螂一样乱窜，试图不发出任何声音，同时绝望地寻找烂地板上的结孔。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Eventually, I just lay down flat against the tile of the kitchen floor, listening. Lying flat against the tile of my kitchen floor listening to someone else have sex is essentially my 20s in a nutshell.
最后，我只是平躺在厨房的瓷砖地板上听着。平躺在厨房瓷砖地板上听别人做爱，本质上就是我20多岁的缩影。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I was robbed in that neighborhood twice. And there were days when it hardly seemed worth it to live in a horrible part of town, just so that I could go daily to a stupid, soul-crushing, low-paying job, especially since as deeply as I yearned to be creative, for years and years, I was too scared to even try. So I did nothing. But here's something that I did do-- I paid my fucking rent.
我在那个社区被抢劫过两次。有些日子，住在那种可怕的地方简直不值得，仅仅为了每天去那份愚蠢的、灵魂破碎的、低薪的工作，尤其是我多年来渴望成为创造者，却因为害怕而甚至不敢尝试。所以我什么都没做。但有一件事我做了——我交了我的混蛋房租。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[APPLAUSE, CHEERS]
[掌声，欢呼声]
The late David Rakoff. His essay about the musical Rent appears in his book Half Empty. But really, you can't go wrong with any of his books. Coming up, proof that some people simply should not go on vacation. They can't hack it. They cannot handle the mellow. That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
已故的大卫·拉科夫。他关于《吉屋出租》音乐剧的散文出现在他的书《半空》中。但真的，买他的任何书都不会错。接下来，证明有些人确实不该去度假。他们应付不来。他们无法驾驭那种悠闲。那一分钟后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Got You Pegged-- stories of people making grand assumptions about other people, sometimes correct, sometimes deeply incorrect. Today's show is a rerun. We've arrived at Act 4 of our show. Act 4, Paradise Lost. Shalom Auslander has our story.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“看透你了”——讲述人们对他人做出宏大假设的故事，有时是正确的，有时是极其错误的。今天的节目是重播。我们到达了节目的第四幕。第四幕，失乐园。沙洛姆·奥斯兰德带来了我们的故事。
I ruin vacations. That's just what I do. In Greece, I was sure the hotel had stuck us with the worst room in the building, even though every room was identical. I know that because we switched three times the day we got there. We switched again the morning after and went home two days early. A year later, I spent four days in a Jamaican rainforest complaining about the weather. We're in a rainforest, my wife said. So? So it rains. We went home two days early.
我毁掉了度假。我就是这样的人。在希腊，我确信酒店给了我们楼里最差的房间，尽管每个房间都一模一样。我知道这一点，因为我们到那儿的第一天就换了三次房。第二天早上我们又换了一次，提前两天回家了。一年后，我在牙买加雨林待了四天，抱怨天气。我们正在雨林里，我妻子说。那又怎样？所以？所以它下雨了。我们提前两天回家了。
And so last year, when my wife informed me that she had booked us a six-day vacation in Anguilla, a remote island in the British West Indies, I decided that this time would be different. It was our first trip in a while, and I'd been doing a lot of work on myself. With the money I'd spent on therapy, I could have bought the whole damn island of Anguilla. So I was anxious to see how far I'd come.
所以去年，当妻子告诉我她帮我们在安圭拉（英属西印度群岛的一个偏远岛屿）预订了六天假期时，我决定这次会不同。这是我们很久以来的第一次旅行，我一直在做自我提升工作。花在治疗上的钱，我都够买下整个安圭拉岛了。所以我很急切地想看看我进步了多少。
The resort was far more expensive than we could afford. I suspected that my wife was hoping that an exclusive resort would minimize the number of disappointments that could inevitably set me off. There was no need for her to worry. This time would be different. This time, I would be different.
这个度假村的价格远超我们的承受能力。我怀疑我妻子是希望一个独家度假村能把不可避免会让我发火的失望事件减到最少。她不必担心。这次会不同。这次，我会变得不同。
The resort we flew to sits tucked away on the eastern end of an utterly pristine inlet of blue-green water on the southern tip of the island. The bellman brought our bags into our room, warned us not to feed the iguanas, wished us a happy stay, and left. My son started jumping on the bed. My wife joined him. And I pulled open the wooden louvered patio doors that led out to the beach.
我们飞往的度假村坐落在岛屿南端一个完全原始的蓝绿色水域的东部一角，隐秘地藏在那里。行李员把我们的行李搬进房间，警告我们不要喂鬣蜥，祝我们入住愉快，然后离开了。我儿子开始在床上跳。我妻子加入了他的行列。我拉开了通往海滩的木制百叶窗露台门。
Wow, I said, as I stepped out onto the patio. For once, the view looked exactly as it had on the website. Pelicans circled above the calm, still waters. The owner's golden retrievers slept peacefully in the shade beneath a gentle, spreading palm. My wife came up behind me and put her arms around my waist. It's Eden, she said. Paradise, I answered. Not a cloud in the sky, she said. Not a single cloud, I said.
“哇，”我走上露台时说道。这景色看起来和网站上一模一样。鹈鹕在平静的水面上盘旋。业主的金毛猎犬在舒展的棕榈树荫下安详地睡着。妻子走过来，搂住我的腰。“这是伊甸园，”她说。“天堂，”我回答。“天空没云，”她说。“没一朵云，”我说。
And then she went inside. When I came in, she already had her beach bag packed and was pulling a T-shirt over our son's head. We're going to the beach, she said. You coming? I'll come down after I unpack, I said. They hurried out the door, dropped a cracker for the iguana waiting in the shade at the bottom of the steps, and headed down to the beach. I quickly put away our clothing, grabbed the room key, and locked the patio door as I closed it behind me.
然后她进屋了。等我进去时，她已经装好了沙滩包，正把T恤套在我儿子的头上。“我们要去海滩，”她说。“你要来吗？”“我整理完行李就下去，”我说。他们匆匆跑出门，给等在台阶底部阴影里的鬣蜥丢了一块饼干，然后朝海滩走去。我快速把衣服收好，拿上房门钥匙，关上露台门并将其锁上。
Hello, said the old man. He was standing at the foot of our patio, holding on to the rail for support. Oh, hello, I said. His name was Marvin, and he'd been coming to the resort for 25 years. Oh, 25 years at least, he said. Maybe more. Such a long time ago. Let's see, I'm 81 now. Yeah, the first time I came here was in, oh, let's see, 1980, I believe. Really? I said, backing my way towards the beach.
“你好，”老男人说。他站在我们露台的脚下，扶着栏杆支撑身体。“哦，你好，”我说。他叫马文，已经在度假村住了25年了。“哦，至少25年了，”他说。“可能更久。很久以前了。看看，我现在81岁了。是的，我第一次来这儿是在……哦，看看，1980年，我想。真的吗？”我说着，退向海滩。
Here's the thing about people. I don't really like them. That's why I find racism so curious. There are so many reasons to dislike people. You're going to go with color? So I avoid the people whenever possible, try to keep my distance. It's really better for everyone.
关于人，我不太喜欢他们。这就是为什么我觉得种族歧视如此奇怪。讨厌人的理由太多了。你偏偏要选肤色？所以我尽可能避开人，尽量保持距离。这对每个人都好。
Could have been 1982, Marvin continued, or maybe even 1978, now that I think about it. No, no, it was 1980. I remember because I was arguing with my wife about Reagan. Whew, boy, did she hate him. Uh-huh, I said. I looked toward the beach and could see my wife and son running down to the water with his pail and shovel. Well, I better go. Family's waiting for me and all.
“可能是1982年，”马文继续说，“或者现在想来甚至可能是1978年。不，不，是1980年。我记得是因为我和妻子在争论里根。呼，天哪，她多讨厌他啊。”“嗯，”我说。我看向海滩，看到妻子和儿子正带着桶和铲子跑到水边。“好吧，我得走了。家人在等我之类的。”
She's dead now, he said. He gently cleared his throat and looked to the ground. Damn it, I thought. I'm sorry, I said. She was a good woman, he said. I nodded. I'm sure, I said. Hotel was very different back then, of course, Marvin continued. Very, very different. The restaurant wasn't where it is now, no, sir. That building wasn't even built until 1990 or so, maybe '92 even. Fellow named Jeremiah built it with his own two hands, by gosh. Nobody builds like that anymore.
“她现在去世了，”他说。他轻轻清了清嗓子，看向地面。“见鬼，”我想。我表示抱歉，“她是个好女人，”他说。我点点头，“我肯定，”我说。“当时的酒店和现在很不一样，当然，”马文继续说。“非常，非常不同。餐厅不是现在这个位置，不是的。那座建筑直到1990年左右，甚至可能是92年才建起来。一个叫杰里迈亚的人亲手建造的，天哪。现在没人那样盖房子了。”
As Marvin rambled on, I began to wonder, was there any way I could switch rooms without upsetting my wife? But I stopped myself, pulled myself together. Not this time, I thought. We are having a pleasant vacation.
随着马文的唠叨，我开始想，有没有什么办法能在不惹毛妻子的前提下换房间？但我克制住了，振作起来。这次不行，我想。我们正在享受愉快的假期。
Is that your wife? Marvin asked. Yeah, I said, waiting for me. She's beautiful, said Marvin. Yeah, I said. Well, I better skedaddle. My wife was beautiful, too. Uh-huh, I said, with a wave. Well, I'll see you later. Marvin waved back, walked up the steps of the villa directly adjoining ours, took out his key, and walked inside. The door closed, and the expectorating began.
“那是你妻子吗？”马文问。“是的，”我说，“在等我。”“她很美，”马文说。“是的，”我说，“好吧，我得溜了。我的妻子也很美。”“嗯，”我说着挥了挥手。“好吧，回头见。”马文挥手回应，走上直接连接我们别墅的台阶，拿出钥匙，走了进去。门关上了，吐痰声开始了。
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
[HACKING, SPITTING]
[清嗓子，吐痰声]
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
Damn it, I thought. The trip had exhausted our son, so we had an early dinner and went for a short sunset stroll on the beach. Thanks, said my wife, putting her arm through mine. For what? I asked. For being so good about things. I smiled and squeezed her arm. Our son ran through the gentle surf and shrieked with joy. Soon he grew tired, climbed into my wife's arms, and we reluctantly climbed the patio steps back to the room.
“该死，”我想。这次旅行耗尽了我儿子的体力，所以我们早早吃了晚饭，在海滩上进行了短暂的日落漫步。“谢谢，”妻子说，挽起我的胳膊。“为了什么？”我问。“为了你在这些事上表现得这么好。”我微笑并捏了捏她的胳膊。儿子跑过轻柔的浪花，高兴地尖叫。不久他累了，爬进妻子的怀里，我们不情愿地爬上露台台阶回到房间。
Good night, said Marvin. He was sitting on his patio next door. Good night, whispered my wife. Where in New York are you from? Asked Marvin. Upstate, she whispered, as she carried our exhausted son into the room. I spent a lot of time there, said Marvin. Hudson Valley, I think it was. Might have been the Catskills. Yeah, I think it was the Catskills. My wife and I used to take our kids up there when they were younger.
“晚安，”马文说。他正坐在隔壁的露台上。“晚安，”妻子低声说。“你们是纽约哪儿的？”马文问。“北部，”她低声说着，把疲惫的儿子抱进房间。我 spent “我在那里待了很长时间，”马文说。“哈德逊河谷，我想是。可能是卡茨基尔。是的，我想是卡茨基尔。我和妻子年轻时常带孩子们去那儿。”
OK, I whispered. We don't talk much anymore-- my kids, I mean. Not my wife. She's dead. Sure, I whispered. Well, good night. I closed the door behind me and locked it. Jesus Christ, I said. You OK? Asked my wife. I'm fine, I said with a smile. We put our son to bed, crept quietly out the back door, and lay down together on a lounge chair underneath the stars. I love you, said my wife. I love you, too, I answered.
“好的，”我低声说，“我们不再怎么说话了——我是说我的孩子们。不是我妻子。她去世了。”“当然，”我低声说，“好吧，晚安。”我关上门并锁好。“耶稣基督，”我说。“你还好吗？”妻子问。“我很好，”我微笑着说。我们把儿子安顿好，静静地爬出门，躺在一起看星星下的躺椅。“我爱你，”妻子说。“我也爱你，”我回答。
[HACKING] came the sound from next door.
[咳痰声] 从隔壁传来。
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
[HACKING]
[咳痰声]
[COUGH]
[咳嗽声]
We lay there a while longer, holding hands in the cool tropical night breeze, watching the shimmering lights of long-dead stars and pretending we weren't listening to an old man drowning in his own phlegm.
我们在清凉的热带晚风中躺了一会儿，手牵手看着早已熄灭的恒星闪烁的光芒，假装我们没有听到一个老人在自己的痰液中淹没。
[HACKING]
[咳痰声]
I awoke the following morning in a dark mood. I didn't want my wife to see it, so I crept out of bed, quietly dressed, and went for a walk. I made my way to the open-air restaurant that overlooked the sea and sat down for an early breakfast. OK, I thought. So there's an old man next door. Was that worth ruining our whole vacation?
第二天早上，我在阴郁的心情中醒来。我不希望妻子看到，于是悄悄起床，穿好衣服，出去散步。我走到海边的露天餐厅，坐下吃早饭。好吧，我想。隔壁有个老头。这值得毁了我们整个假期吗？
I'd worked too long and too hard on myself to be derailed by this. I decided to view Marvin as some sort of a test. Maybe it was God's test. Maybe it was just fate. But I was stronger than Marvin. I was stronger than a thousand Marvins. He would not defeat me. I finished my breakfast and walked back to the room.
我在自我提升上花了太长时间、太多的努力，不能被这件事破坏。我决定把马文看作某种考验。也许这是上帝的考验。也许只是宿命。但我比马文坚强。我比一千个马文还要坚强。他打败不了我。我吃完早饭，走回房间。
Good morning, said Marvin. He was sitting at his patio table, finishing his breakfast. Good morning, I said. A lovely day, isn't it? Oh, it is, he said. Mornings like this, my wife and I used to get up early and go for a long swim. That sounds nice, I said. She's dead now, he said. Hey, I said, who isn't? That's true, said Marvin. I looked out over the beach and smiled. Check and mate, Marv. I was unflappable.
“早安，”马文说。他正坐在露台桌旁吃早饭。“早安，”我说，“天气真好，不是吗？”“哦，是的，”他说，“像这样的早晨，我和妻子常起得很早去游泳。”“听起来不错，”我说。“她现在去世了，”他说。“嘿，”我说，“谁不是呢？”“那是真的，”马文说。我看着海滩，微笑。将死，马文。我处变不惊。
Auschwitz, said Marvin. I turned around. Sorry? My wife, she died in Auschwitz. We were quite young, only married a few years. Auschwitz, I said. Marvin nodded. We were sent to Dachau at first, but after a few weeks, they sent us to Auschwitz. Auschwitz, I said.
“奥斯威辛，”马文说。我转过身。“对不起？”“我的妻子，她死在奥斯威辛。我们很年轻，才结婚几年。”“奥斯威辛，”我说。马文点点头。“我们最初被送到达豪，但几周后，他们把我们送到奥斯威辛。”“奥斯威辛，”我说。
Sure, my mother, too. She was sent to Bergen-Belsen. But that's not where she died. She died in Auschwitz with my father, probably of pneumonia. That's what I heard. My father was shot. The Nazis shot him. I know this from some people in Miami who knew him in the camps. Ethel, Morris Goldstein. They died a while ago.
“当然，我母亲也是。她被送到卑尔根-贝尔森。但她不是在那儿死的。她和父亲一起死在奥斯威辛，大概是死于肺炎。这是我听说的。我父亲被枪杀了。纳粹枪杀了他。我是从迈阿密的一些在集中营认识他们的人那儿听说的。埃塞尔、莫里斯·戈尔茨坦。他们很久以前就去世了。”
I should have been compassionate. I know. I should have taken a pad and pen and committed his story to paper for future generations. But I didn't. Instead, I seethed. 20 minutes of genocide stories later, I went into our villa, closed the door sharply behind me, and stood in the center of the room with my hands on my hips. What? Asked my wife. I threw my hands into the air. Auschwitz, I said. Pardon? Auschwitz. What are you talking about? She asked. Au-freaking-schwitz. He's a survivor, hon, a Holocaust survivor.
我本该表现出同情心的。我知道。我本该拿出纸笔，把他的故事写下来留给后代。但我没有。相反，我怒火中烧。20分钟的种族灭绝故事后，我走进别墅，猛地关上门，双手叉腰站在房间中央。“什么？”妻子问。我双手高举。“奥斯威辛，”我说。“什么？”“奥斯威辛。你在说什么？”她问。“奥——该死的——斯威辛。他是幸存者，亲爱的，大屠杀幸存者。”
I don't have anything against Holocaust survivors. Some of my best friends are Holocaust survivors. OK, that's not actually true, but I don't have anything against them. But if I want to relax and forget about life for a while, maybe hit a bar and have a drink, I'm not going to call Elie Wiesel. Hey, Elie. How's it going? I had a tough day. Why don't you come over, and we'll watch Schindler's List? Bring beer.
我对大屠杀幸存者没什么意见。我最好的朋友中有些是大屠杀幸存者。好吧，那不是真的，但我对他们没什么反感。但如果我想放松一下，忘掉生活一段时间，也许去酒吧喝一杯，我是不会找埃利·威塞尔的。“嘿，埃利。最近怎么样？我过得很艰难。为什么不过来，我们一起看《辛德勒的名单》？带上啤酒。”
A Holocaust survivor, I said, pacing back and forth across the room. The place is half-empty, and the guy next door is a Holocaust survivor. I think I've been pretty good about this. I didn't let the travel upset me. I didn't let the hacking next door all night long get to me. But this is too much. It's too much. I'm standing in paradise, talking about gas chambers.
“一个大屠杀幸存者，”我焦躁地在房间里走来走去，“酒店半空着，隔壁那家伙是个大屠杀幸存者。我觉得我已经表现得很好了。我没让旅行扫兴。我没让整夜的咳痰声影响我。但这太过分了。这太多了。我站在天堂，谈论毒气室。”
My wife was sympathetic, but she'd seen this before and insisted I was blowing it out of proportion. As usual, she said. And I said, What's that supposed to mean? And she said, You know what that means. And I said, No, I don't. And less than 24 hours after our plane touched down in Eden, we were fighting.
我妻子很同情，但她以前见过这种情况，坚持说我夸大其词。“一如既往，”她说。我说，“那是什么意思？”她说，“你知道是什么意思。”我说，“不，我不知道。”在我们飞机降落在伊甸园不到24小时后，我们就吵架了。
It's your decision, she said to me, as she gathered her beach things together. He's not ruining our vacation. You are. No, I'm not! I shouted. Goebbels is. Blame Goebbels. She walked out and stomped down the patio steps. My son began to cry. A dozen iguanas sat on the deck. Two of them ran inside and hid under the bed. Damn it, I thought.
“这是你的决定，”她说着，一边收拾沙滩用品，“他没毁掉我们的假期。是你。”“不，我没有！”我大喊，“是戈培尔。去怪戈培尔。”她走了出去，重重地走下露台台阶。我儿子开始哭。十几只鬣蜥坐在露台上。两只跑进屋躲在床下。“该死，”我想。
I spent the next few hours avoiding my wife, hoping that a little time would settle things down between us. I took my son and walked over to the front office. Did you feed them? The man asked. We told you not to feed them. They're in our room, I said. They're under our bed.
接下来的几个小时我都在躲着妻子，希望时间能平息我们之间的矛盾。我带着儿子走到办公室。“你们喂它们了吗？”男人问，“我们告诉过你们不要喂它们。它们在我们的房间里，”我说，“它们在我们的床下。”
I heard laughter coming from the lobby and poked my head around the corner. Marvin was sitting in a wicker chair, surrounded by a half a dozen adoring hotel employees. A waiter from the bar brought him a rum punch. Let me pay you, said Marvin. No, no, Mr. Marvin, said the waiter. No, no. If there's anything worse than hating someone, it's discovering that everyone else loves them.
我听到大堂传来笑声，探头一看。马文坐在藤椅上，被半打崇拜的酒店员工包围着。酒吧里的服务员给他拿了一杯朗姆潘趣酒。“让我付钱，”马文说。“不，不，马文先生，”服务员说，“不，不。”如果说有什么比讨厌一个人更糟糕的事，那就是发现其他人竟然都爱他。
Oh, Mr. Marvin, an attractive female chambermaid cried. He's terrible! The man at the front desk smiled in Marvin's direction. What a sweet man, he said, and then shook his head. And what he's been through.
“哦，马文先生，”一位迷人的女房务员尖叫道，“他太棒了！”前台的男人朝着马文微笑。“多可爱的人啊，”他说，然后摇了摇头，“他经历过什么啊。”
At dinner that evening, Marvin sat at the resort owner's table. My wife and I sat nearby, barely talking. Marvin told funny stories, and everyone laughed. Marvin told sad stories about the Holocaust, I guessed, judging by the horror on the face of his dinner companions, and everyone hugged him. And when the bill came and Marvin reached for it, again, they refused to let him pay. That was when I decided with absolute certainty that the son-of-a-bitch was faking it.
那天晚餐时，马文坐在度假村业主的桌旁。我和妻子坐在附近，几乎没说话。马文讲着有趣的故事，大家都笑了。马文讲着关于大屠杀的悲伤故事（我想，看他餐伴脸上恐惧的表情），大家都拥抱他。当账单来了，马文伸手去拿时，他们又拒绝让他付钱。就在那一刻，我极其确定那个混蛋是装的。
Holocaust survivor, my ass, I thought. I grew up in an Orthodox Jewish community. I've known Holocaust survivors, OK? And they don't go on and on about it. Elie Wiesel doesn't go on about it. Marvin was no Holocaust survivor. He was just an old chatterbox looking for a meal ticket.
大屠杀幸存者，我才不信，我想。我在一个正统犹太社区长大。我知道大屠杀幸存者，好吗？他们不会没完没了地讲那件事。埃利·威塞尔也不会没完没了地讲。马文根本不是什么大屠杀幸存者。他只是一个找饭票的老唠叨鬼。
There's no such thing as a free lunch until you tell everyone sitting next to you at lunch about your stay in Bergen-Belsen. Marvin was faking, I was sure of it. And I was equally sure that if I could just prove that to my wife, all would be forgiven. And I knew just how to do it.
没有免费的午餐，直到你告诉午餐时坐在你旁边的每个人关于你在卑尔根-贝尔森的经历。马文是装的，我对此深信不疑。我也同样确定，如果我能证明这一点给我妻子看，一切都会被原谅。而且我知道该怎么做。
We came back from dinner, and I put my son into his pajamas and read him some stories. My wife sang him some songs and put him to bed. And after that, she put on her shoes and said she needed to take a walk. Fine, I said. Good, she answered. Great, I said. Whatever, she replied.
我们晚餐回来，我让儿子换上睡衣，给他讲了些故事。妻子唱了些歌让他入睡。之后，她穿上鞋说她需要去散步。“行，”我说。“好，”她回答。“太棒了，”我回答。“随便你，”她回答。
I went outside, sat down on the patio steps, and watched the ocean, hoping it would calm me down. Suddenly, I heard a groan coming from Marvin's patio. I stood up, peeked over the fence that separated our two patios, and saw him asleep on one of his lounge chairs. This was my chance.
我走到外面，坐在露台台阶上，看着大海，希望它能让我冷静下来。突然，我听到马文的露台传来一声呻吟。我站起来，窥视分隔我们两个露台的栅栏，看到他在他的躺椅上睡着了。这是我的机会。
I looked around to see if anyone was watching, went over to his patio, and crept up the stairs. He rustled, and I froze. After a few seconds, I tiptoed over to where he was sleeping. His left arm was propped behind his head, but his right arm was stretched out along the arm of the chair. Bingo. I made my way back to our room and waited anxiously for my wife to return.
我环顾四周看看有没有人看，走到他的露台，轻手轻脚地爬上台阶。他动了一下，我僵住了。几秒钟后，我踮着脚尖走到他睡觉的地方。他的左臂撑在脑后，但右臂沿着椅子的扶手伸出来。宾果。我回到了我们的房间，焦急地等待妻子的归来。
A few minutes later, the front door opened. Well, well, well, I said, as she came into the room. Well, well what? She asked. Well, well, well. I guess Mr. Auschwitz isn't such a survivor after all. What are you talking about? She asked. I held my arm out and pointed to my forearm. No numbers, I said with a smile. At last, I'd gotten a clean look at his forearm, and no numbers. What? Asked my wife. No numbers. If he was in the Holocaust, where are the numbers?
几分钟后，前门开了。“好，好，好，”她进房间时我说。“好什么？”她问。“好，好，好。我想奥斯威辛先生并不是什么幸存者。”“你在说什么？”她问。我伸出胳膊，指着我的前臂。“没有数字，”我笑着说。终于，我清晰地看到了他的前臂，没有数字。“什么？”妻子问。“没有数字。如果他经历了大屠杀，数字在哪儿？”
Her face dropped. What did you do? She asked. What? What did you do? I didn't do anything. Did you ask him to show you his numbers? Bloody hell, Shal. Did you ask him to show you his numbers? I didn't ask him to show me his numbers, I said. He was sleeping.
她的脸垮了下来。“你做了什么？”她问。“什么？你做了什么？”“我什么都没做。”“你让他给你看数字了？该死的，沙尔。你让他给你看数字了？”“我没让他给我看数字，”我说，“他在睡觉。”
She pressed her fingertips against her eyes and shook her head. And why exactly would he lie about being in the Holocaust? Why? I asked. Free stuff. They pay for all his meals. They probably pay for his room. He's faking it. This is ludicrous. Why would he pick the Holocaust? What's he going to say, Bataan Death March? It was a hike. Get over it. You want free stuff, you go with Holocaust.
她用指尖按住眼睛，摇了摇头。“他为什么要谎称自己经历了大屠杀？为什么？”我问。“免费东西。他们付了他所有的饭钱。他们可能还付了他的房钱。他是装的。这太荒谬了。他为什么选大屠杀？他要说什么，巴丹死亡行军？那是一次徒步旅行。算了吧。想要免费东西，你就选大屠杀。”
Which arm? She asked. What? Which arm did you check? I paused. The right one, I said. She looked at me. They tattooed the left? She nodded. And they didn't tattoo everyone. How do you know? My neighbors were survivors, she said, both neighbors. None of them had numbers. She kicked her shoes off and headed for the bathroom. This isn't about Marvin, she said. This isn't about numbers or concentration camps. This is about you.
“哪只胳膊？”她问。“什么？你检查了哪只胳膊？”我停顿了一下，“右边，”我说。她看着我，“他们刺在左边？”她点点头，“而且他们不是每个人都刺。你怎么知道？”“我的邻居是幸存者，”她说，“两个邻居都是。他们都没有数字。”她踢掉鞋子，朝浴室走去，“这不是马文的事，”她说，“这不是关于数字或集中营的事。这是关于你的事。”
All that night and into the next morning, I couldn't sleep. I lay in bed, imagining that I'd proved to everyone what a fraud Marvin was. I pictured finding a photo of him circa 1940, somewhere in Miami. I pictured calling the Holocaust Museum in DC. Marvin? They would say. We have no record of a Marvin.
那天晚上一直到第二天早上，我都睡不着。我躺在床上，想象着我向所有人证明了马文是个骗子。我设想找到一张他在1940年左右在迈阿密的照片。我设想给华盛顿的大屠杀博物馆打电话。“马文？”他们会说，“我们没有任何关于马文的记录。”
I pictured confronting him at dinner, catching him out on some esoteric German historical fact. Wrong. Himmler didn't take over the Gestapo until 1934. Ha! But mostly, I just felt awful. A full third of our first family vacation was over, and we'd spent most of it fighting. I was sure our son sensed it, sure that he would hold it against me. Sure I was wrong, but sure I was right.
我设想在晚餐时面对他，用深奥的德国历史事实戳穿他。错。希姆莱直到1934年才接管盖世太保。哈！但大部分时间，我只是感到糟糕透顶。我们第一次家庭度假的三分之一已经过去了，我们大部分时间都在吵架。我确信我儿子感觉得到，确信他会因此记恨我。确信我错了，但确信我是对的。
At the first sign of daybreak, I got out of bed and went down to the beach. I walked south along the entire length of the shore before turning around and heading back. As I grew closer to the beach across from our villa, I saw something dark and heavy in the shallow water. I thought it was a log or a mass of seaweed, but then I saw it was moving. It was kicking. It was a person. And as I grew closer still, I realized it was Marvin. It was Marvin, and he was struggling to get to shore.
破晓时分，我起床去海滩。我沿着海岸线往南走了一整段，然后掉头往回。当我走近我们别墅对面的海滩时，我看到浅水里有一个又黑又重的东西。我以为那是根木头或一团海藻，但随后我看到它在动。它在踢。是个人。当我走得更近时，我意识到是马文。是马文，他正在挣扎着上岸。
I hate to admit it, but even as I ran to help him, I was pissed off. It was bad enough I had to put up with this pain in the ass. Now I had to save him? I grabbed Marvin around his chest, lifting and pulling as I swung his arm across my shoulder. He was coughing, spluttering, trying to catch his breath. I'm all right, he was saying. I'm all right. I helped him onto the beach. I was breathing heavily.
我很不情愿承认，但即使在我跑去救他时，我也火大。我忍受这个讨厌鬼已经够糟了。现在我还得救他？我抓住马文的胸口，把他提起，把他的胳膊架在我的肩膀上。他在咳嗽，吐着唾沫，试图吸气。“我没事，”他说，“我没事。”我把他扶上岸。我气喘吁吁。
That, I said, was the most pathetic cry for attention I have ever seen. Marvin laughed and took a moment to catch his breath. My wife, he said. Yeah, I said. Auschwitz. He shook his head. Second wife, he said. We came here together for 25 years. We used to get up for early morning swims. As I got older, it got harder for me to get back to the shore-- undertow and all. She would stand at the edge and wait for me to come back. She sounds great, I said. She was, said Marvin.
“那，”我说，“是我见过最可怜的求关注方式。”马文笑了笑，花了一会儿平复呼吸。“我的妻子，”他说。“是啊，”我说，“奥斯威辛。”他摇摇头，“第二任妻子，”他说，“我们一起在那儿住了25年。我们常起来早泳。我老了以后，很难再回到岸边——回流什么的。她会站在边缘等我回来。”“她听起来很棒，”我说。“她是，”马文说。
I shook my head. Such a shame she wasted all those years with you. Marvin laughed again. We have the same sense of humor, he said. We should spend more time together. I stood up, wiped the sand from my legs and hands, and uttered the most honest thing I'd said to Marvin since I met him. That sounds awful.
我摇摇头，“真可惜她和你浪费了那么多年。”马文又笑了，“我们有同样的幽默感，”他说，“我们应该多待在一起。”我站起来，擦掉腿和手上的沙子，说了我从见到马文以来最真诚的一句话：“那听起来太糟糕了。”
Marvin smiled, and we walked back to our rooms. And after that moment, he never bothered me again. I'd wasted three days trying to be polite to someone I couldn't stand and nearly ruined another vacation. But by finally being the ass I really am, I'd saved it.
马文笑了，我们走回房间。从那一刻起，他再没烦过我。我浪费了三天试图对一个我无法忍受的人礼貌，差点又毁了一个假期。但通过终于成为我本性中那个混蛋的样子，我拯救了它。
I was cordial enough. Marvin waved when I saw him in the TV room, telling Holocaust stories to the young couple who checked in that evening, and I waved back. He nodded when I saw him at breakfast the following morning, telling a pair of young waitresses about mass graves in Sobibor, and I nodded back.
我足够客气了。我在电视室看到马文时会招手，他正给那天刚入住的年轻夫妇讲大屠杀故事，我也招手回应。第二天早上吃早饭看到他点头致意时，他正在给两个年轻女服务员讲索比堡的乱葬坑，我也点头回应。
And then we finished our breakfast. And my wife took my hand in hers, and she smiled at me, and I smiled at her. And together, we walked arm in arm to watch the sun still rising over the unspoiled beach below.
然后我们吃完了早饭。妻子握住我的手，对我微笑，我也对她微笑。我们手臂挽着手臂，看着太阳在下方未被污染的海滩上徐徐升起。
Shalom Auslander. He's the author most recently of the memoir Feh.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他最近的回忆录《Feh》的作者。
["BE CAREFUL OF THE STONES YOU THROW" BY SHIRLEY CAESAR]
["小心你扔出的石头" - 雪莉·凯撒]
Well, our program was produced today by Robyn Semien and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Marie, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show, Julie Snyder. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Help on today's rerun from Suzanne Gaber and Stowe Nelson.
好吧，我们今天的节目由罗宾·塞米恩和我本人制作，参与人员还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、简·玛丽、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。音乐协助杰西卡·霍珀。重播协助苏珊·加伯和斯托·尼尔森。
Special thanks today to Kim Heavner and Katie Stallman at Open Adoption and Family Services. The adoption agency in the Pacific Northwest had hooked us up with Kim in Act 3. Their website, openadopt.org. Thanks also to [? Don ?] [? Friedman ?] and Lea Thau, Catherine Burns and Meg McIntyre of The Moth.
特别感谢今天“开放式领养与家庭服务”的金·海夫纳和凯蒂·斯托尔曼。这家太平洋西北部的领养机构在第三幕中把金介绍给了我们。他们的网站，openadopt.org。还要感谢“Moth”的唐·弗里德曼、莉亚·陶、凯瑟琳·伯恩斯和梅格·麦金太尔。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who joins me right now in the studio today. Torey, get a little closer to the microphone. OK? Hey, are you feeling OK?
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他现在正在录音室里陪我。托里，靠近麦克风一点。好吗？嘿，你感觉还好吗？
[COUGHING]
[咳嗽声]
[HACKING]
[咳痰声]
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[HACKING]
[咳痰声]